back to school
at least for now
sri lanka's new president ranil vikram
singha and his government want to show
things are returning to normal
schools have been asked to start on-site
lessons three days a week the other day
students are taught online
but many say the fuel shortage and
economic crisis are still a major
obstacle
i faced a lot of hardships due to the
fuel crisis i'm a mother and a teacher
and i had to queue for two days to get
fuel
we have to wait 30 to 40 minutes for a
three-wheeler taxi and even if we get
one we are helpless with unfair charges
today i paid double the usual fare
the head of sri lanka's teachers union
told al jazeera its members are also
having transport issues
he urged the government to declare
education and essential service giving
it the priority it deserves
schools were closed because there was no
fuel even today that's the situation
with endless cues
as a trade union we don't want schools
to stay closed because the longer that
happens the greater the impact on
students
nearly 30 000 school vans operate around
the country
drivers and other school workers are
hoping the arrangement made this week
will continue
it's best that fuel is continued to be
provided to us through the bus depots
because it's not possible for us to
queue overnight and then drive children
to school in the morning
this is very difficult
fuel is not the only problem
skyrocketing prices have seen school
transport fees double in recent months
and many families have been forced to
look for cheaper options
students have not been spared the
effects of sri lanka's worst economic
crisis in decades but following two
years of pandemic related lockdowns it's
not been easy mine fernandez al jazeera
colombo